deal oh here's this basketball player
yeah very handsome this is part three
that we're talking about prior today it
was part two where puppet but they left
and I'm really sad oh wait was this
Italian among the artists Peppa left him
beginning of part three actually there
are many a part that he was there for
the first episode part three where he
finally saw his his first publish yeah
Pepe is a really cool dude he's an
Italian manga artist that moved to Japan
he was a I forgot what inspired him
exactly but he came here to become a
manga artist and so his goal in the
house was to make sure that that dream
came true yeah and it finally did and
what it did is was it was his time to
leave oh yeah and that's it was it was
interesting because the first time he
ever saw his manga get published he went
to a convenience store and oh my god
this woman was crying her eyes out cut
it was such a great moment where he was
just celebrating on his own he looked at
it read it looked through all the pages
realizing that it's published it's out
there and nobody was around him he
didn't celebrate it with you know
friends or whatever he just looked at it
enjoyed in like absorb that moment and
it was silent and I was just tearing up
because he could see how they're turning
up right now as you're thinking about
how hard he worked and it just like
[Laughter]
Mariel is a very censor so this is one
of my funniest stories that she's ever
done so just to go back on the topic of
us watching movies but she so you guys
remember you know Paul Walker rest in
peace he passed foot it so we went to go
watch Fast and Furious it was the last
film that he was in where they had to
put him in CG towards the end this one
is so ridiculous we're watching the film
and there's that part where Coast he's
spittin all day without you my friend
you know that song and then Paul Walker
is in his car he looks over at Dom
Toretto they kind of smile as a CG
version of himself
and these all you mean Don Toretto his
Vin Diesel as these actor names and I
was like ok and then so he desperate
miss my bed but as these driving off
they kind of look at each other and that
song comes on and I see Mariel bawling
her eyes out as if she was at a Funeral
like you were crying nobody like I
understand the tears part right but the
amount that you were crying was unreal
and I'm invested okay I grew up watching
Fast and the Furious I watched most of
the sequels
so I'm invested in this so did I but the
way you have no emotion I know I was a
very emotional part but it's not the
fact that you cried it was how much you
were crying that threw me off
let's talk did it help the one she
responded to was the most ridiculous
thing I've ever heard I go what like in
the theater she goes it's my final
goodbye it's my final goodbye invested
in these okay when I watch it I imagine
myself being in that moment in that
story
that's why when it when Pepe was looking
at and nothing was happening it was the
grandma that was there that Viking sent
it over the edge it did it said I was
getting very emotional when I was just
like man I'm so proud of you I don't
even know you
Pepe but I know that you were very
passionate you work really hard for it
and then you achieved you composed what
oh my god
I lost the work yeah either way she was
very very emotional at that scene and he
was actually one of my favorite
characters and the reason why is like he
has a quality that I really really enjoy
so and what I mean by that is that I
think like growing up for for me anyways
people were categorized in in certain
things and you couldn't break out of it
like for example if you were a jock you
were a jock and and what came along with
jock was that you were a muscle meathead
that was that would had a very low like
you
that's just what you were right in high
school I think a lot of people do that
if you're if you're a geek you're a nerd
you're the guy that's a point Dexter he
gets good grades he's never gonna get a
girlfriend he's a dweeb whatever
and then what we're finding out now
specifically because of like social
media and people being able to show on
and they're finding that there's a
community outside of this small little
box that people put you in but you can
be multiple things right you can be a
dweeb
that's charismatic this charismatic that
has confidence and that's what Pepe is
Pemba is a [ __ ] dweeb but in the best
way possible
like he's nerdy he likes his little
cartoon his Bond guys and he's kind of
like he's like freaking Italian his [ __ ]
hyper Italian yeah he's a shy Italian
yes like he's a little bit more reserved
than like the typical like machismo
Italian man that you know that you kind
of picture with like a rose in his mouth
making pasta every day yeah what he did
may possible I know and it looks so good
yeah but he kind of like categorizes
what I like about somebody is that you
can be very cool you can be very
charismatic and confident even though
categorically people think you're very
dweeby because dweeb is not an insult
it's just kind of like it is what you
are like you're a dweeb like you're a
geek maybe a geek or nerd or whatever
what doesn't mean that you can't be cool
yeah and that's what I really liked
about him because he kind of he doesn't
he has no shame in he's very true to
himself yes he doesn't perform like you
know when he likes a girl he he shows
who he is yeah he's a good-looking guy
he's like he's not muscular or anything
like that
he's just he has his charisma about him
his confidence he's very goal-oriented
very adorable very passionate he's I
think he has a good sense of humor very
great sense yeah very positive he's very
optimistic you know it's just you see
the bright side of him and I think
that's very attractive and so like and
it's very refreshing for me to see
because I see or I used to see a lot of
people and these are the people that I
distance myself from now it's like
especially like in social media you know
some of these youtubers like when they
were younger
Pournami just use tubers like people who
are actors or whatever for some reason
this is weird habit when people come
into this city they stop being who they
were before because they come into a new
city and they try to create a new
identity but it's like let me tell you
something if you were a dweeb since you
were [ __ ] 2 1 years old like I was
your dweeb all the way through and
through
it seeps out of your skin problem is now
is like what I hate is the it doesn't
have to be a dweeb or a nerd it could be
like a thug or whatever you are who you
are just own it and when you try not be
when you try to be something that you're
not it's so uncomfortable looking at you
and being around you is this are you
talk about people who are adults these
are adults okay yeah because I'm
thinking like well like college people
go to college so like college five find
themselves but they don't know who they
are
yeah so they like put up a face on it
you know they try to become a whole
different person
and I think that's a great face to
explore who you are but then after you
pass her college face like I think
that's when you should be really true to
yourself or try try to figure it out and
it's sad because it's not just a college
thing I thought that in colleges that's
where it would end because it was very
prevalent in college and I would see
that in a lot of people for example
there was a dude that I met in college I
talked about it before with Joe his name
was Andy and long stories like he's a
Chinese dude I can't remember him deal
and I want to say Andy there was one
there was a guy named Andrew Jiang and
there was another dude named Andy god
it's blanking right now but if I think
about it I'll remember his name but long
story short if people haven't heard this
on the previous podcast with Joe and he
was one of those guys that was clearly
like a geek in the worst way possible
not a very cool geek or nerd right it's
like I had this other fight in his name
was Tony mmm-hmm Tony I love this guy to
death he was like a magnet school kid
but just the coolest like nerd dude I
ever met in my life right this other kid
Andy he